one of the things that we've been
talking about is donald trump's
endorsement record donald trump and
others tout the power of the trump
endorsement and indeed donald trump over
the last 48 hours has been posting
uncontrollably uncontrollably
to his uh platform truth social truth
essential and it is all about his
supposed endorsement record check this
out trump spending a lot of time there
trump candidates dominate tuesday's
primary elections
molly hemingway republicans need to
understand why its prospects are so good
trump reshaped the party he's the savior
as far as trump wants you to believe
trump 2024 crushed the establishment
retweeting all sorts of re-truthing all
sorts of different stuff trump endorsed
candidates are ready to take back our
country i guess quoting carrie lake or
who knows who blake masters wins arizona
republican senate primary again the idea
is thanks to trump there rusty bowers
january 6th star witness
loses republican primary in arizona the
idea there is not a trump endorsed guy
and he lost
trump nod spurs dixon to runaway win in
michigan he's responsible there
trump backed gibbs this is the guy i
interviewed trump backed gibbs ousts
meyer in michigan republican race for
congress
um on and just if you scroll down truth
central it is just post after post after
post of donald trump taking credit for
all of these different victories trump
candidates dominate tuesday primaries
again
big historic win for trump endorsed
candidates across the country now 15-0
in senate primaries perfect records in
arizona kansas michigan and missouri
congratulations to our mag i can't this
i could just go and go and go i'm not
going to subject you to this not going
to subject you to this so
what is the truth about donald trump's
endorsement record well there's two
sides to this
one side of it are just the numbers like
are the numbers actually as good as
donald trump claims
and the second part would be
even if the numbers are as good as he
claims
are they meaningful are they
statistically significant when you
consider the circumstances let's go
through it one by one so first and
foremost ballotpedia maintains a page
the endorsements of donald trump
um during trump's presidency there were
305 endorsements since trump left office
there have been 237 additional
endorsements okay so
this year
trump's record
is 92 percent
that's a good record no question about
it
uh we'll get back to that in 2020
trump's endorsement record was 77
in 2019
it was 43 percent in those were special
elections in 2018 trump's record was 58
so let me explain to you what this is
all about all right
when donald trump was actually making
endorsements
uh
in uh general elections
where they were actually contested races
he was basically 50 50. so it's almost
like a coin flip okay
if you consider that trump endorsed some
incumbents there
and that
trump made some endorsements
of individuals who were clearly the
favorite at the time of the endorsement
barely 50 50
isn't particularly impressive
it's just it's a little bit better than
a coin flip and a lot of the times he's
endorsing people who sort of like should
win anyway because they've raised the
most money they're the clear front
runners they're the incumbents so that's
number one
if you look at 2022
trump's record is significantly better
in the primaries because donald trump is
sometimes getting behind the obvious
leader
sometimes that's an incumbent and we
know about the power of incumbency uh
and sometimes trump is is waiting until
the absolute last moment and sometimes
it's very mushy like for example when he
endorsed eric in missouri and two if not
three of the leading candidates were
named eric like are we counting that as
a win i'm not sure whether that counts
here so
it's not a particularly interesting
endorsement story trump's endorsement
history is very 50 50 um and then in
particular in 2022 there's this bias to
just supporting the person already
likely to win now i will give trump
credit
there are a handful of candidates who
were not winning when trump endorsed
them and then they ended up winning and
there's no doubt that trump's
endorsement has some power
the question is going to be
the general election the general
election in the general uh
election endorsements in 2022
trump is 0 for 10.
he's made 10 endorsements in general
elections where it's a democrat versus a
republican and he lost every single one
he doesn't talk about that
so we're going to pay attention to that
very closely as well as many of you know
i'm a busy person i don't always have
the exact correct nutritional plan for
my meals every single day and that's why
i also take a multivitamin and a couple
of supplements but doing them all
separately can be a little bit time
consuming which is why athletic greens
is just fantastic and they're one of our
sponsors i've been using the athletic
greens since last year it just really
simplifies nutrition i just do a scoop
of the ag-1 and i'm getting 75 high
quality vitamins and minerals and my
probiotics and it's all from whole food
sources i drink it in the morning i know
i'm good i don't have to be messing
around with different pills and
supplements or whatever spend time
planning when what time of day do i need
to take each one i just get it all with
one scoop you can put it in a smoothie
you can drink it straight it tastes
great and then i'm just good for the day
it supports gut health and i'm getting
everything that i need and i'm looking
for athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d plus five free travel packs
when you go to athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below